[Music]
you have one of those things that just
reaches people and I feel like opera
kind of specifically has that effect on
everyone more raw and it's beautiful I
do feel like we're making it so everyone
can enjoy it
[Music]
[Applause]
my name is Alexis Krieger and I'm an
opera singer a member of the upper
collective we're about 30 right now we
come together two to three times a week
to bring offer to the people we sing in
the subways of New York City my mom used
to always listen to the Met broadcast
when I was 14 she took me to the met for
the first time and queen of the night
came on stage and I saw her and I said
yeah what I wanted to do for most people
do have that initial feeling of oh I
don't like opera what is this opera but
bringing opera to the subway really
makes it for everyone and it really
makes it something that people feel like
they can connect with
[Music]
it's one of those places where people
just go by everyday all day long and so
you really get to see all walk with
people
[Music]
we've had people come and stand or sit
for practically the entire time were
there we have a note that was given to
us by a girl who was really not doing
that well that day she was sitting on
one of the benches and she was there for
probably close to two hours and at the
end of it she came up and put this note
along with some change into the bucket
[Music]
basically she had said that she's been
contemplating suicide and listening to
us sitting there and hearing that music
it just changed her mind and that's why
we do this I'm so happy that we can make
that sort of impact you know if it's a
really beautiful thing